so let's use integer chips again to
start exploring a little bit more when
we deal with negative numbers so let's
say we wanted to compute what negative
one minus 7 is see if you can pause this
video and figure that out using integer
chips
well let's do this together so we're
starting with negative one we could
represent negative one as just one
integer one negative integer chip
but we need to subtract 7 positive 7
from that we have no positive integer
integer chips here so and we need to
have at least seven positive integer
chips in order to subtract seven so how
could we get some positive integer chips
well we can just add pairs of negative
and positive internships so if I add one
negative integer chip and I add one
positive integer chip just like that
this is still negative one over here
because these two integer chips are
going to cancel each other out so let me
just do that seven times so let me just
do this so that's two three four five
six and seven and then I just have to
add the corresponding positive integer
chips 3 4 5 6 and 7. so notice what I
just wrote this is just another way of
writing negative one but I wrote it this
way because I can actually subtract out
positive 7 now from this so now let's
subtract out positive 7. so
subtract out one two three four five six
seven and then what are we left with
well we're left with all of this
business right over here
and what is that that's one two three
four five six seven eight this is equal
to negative eight now that's interesting
by itself but you might notice something
when what I have left over when I take a
negative one and I subtract positive
seven from that I'm left with
essentially the equivalent of negative
one
and negative seven so another way of
writing what we just have left over here
is I have negative one
as that one negative integer chip right
over there and then I have negative
seven these seven negative integer chips
right over there so you could also view
this as the same thing as negative one
plus
negative seven
and so this makes us think about
something is it true that if I subtract
a positive
that's the same thing as adding the
inverse of that positive adding in in
the case of a positive seven in the case
of subtracting a positive seven that's
going to be the same thing as adding a
negative seven interesting and let's see
actually if it works the other other way
around so let's see what happens when we
subtract a negative so if we have
negative 3 minus negative 5.
maybe maybe this is the same thing as
negative 3 plus the opposite of negative
5 which would be positive 5. let's see
if these two things actually amount to
be the same thing so let's just start
with this first one up here we're going
to start with negative 3 so that gives
us three negative integer chips so
negative one negative two negative 3.
now if we want to subtract out negative
5 if we want to take away five negative
integer chips well we need more negative
integer chips here we need at least two
more negative integer chips so if we
have two more negative integer chips
we're not changing the value of that if
we have two more positive integer chips
what I have depicted here is still
negative 3 because that and that cancel
out and so this is still the number
negative 3 being represented but I added
these two pairs because now I can
subtract out five negative integer chips
that's what negative 5 represents these
top four negative interchips there's
five of them I can take them all away
that's subtracting out a negative 5. and
what am I left with what I'm left with
just these two positive integer chips so
this is going to be equal to positive 2.
well that's interesting because that's
kind of feeling very similar to what we
have here if we start with negative
three so negative 1 negative 2 negative
3 and I add a positive five so five
positive integers one two three four and
five well we already know that that
cancels with that that cancels with that
that cancels with that this is the
equivalent of positive 2. and what I
just did here on both sides this isn't a
proof that this will always work but
hopefully this gives you an intuition
that it does seem to work and I will
tell you that without giving you the
full proof that it actually does always
work that it is actually the case
that if you subtract a number it's the
same thing as adding the opposite of
that number if you subtract a number
it's the same thing as adding the
opposite of that number